[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا لهذه الحلقه الجديده من
مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
الاداره الامريكيه تكشف لمستقبل الطاقه عن
اعاده النظر بقرار السحب من الاحتياطات
البتروليه الاستراتيجيه في سبتمبر المقبل
[موسيقى]
واستثمارات بمليار دولار لتوسعه شبكه
الربط الكهربائي الخليجي
[موسيقى]
خلال اقل من ثلاثه اسابيع سيبدا الحظر
الفعلي لواردات الديزل الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي من اكبر مورد خارجيا وهو روسيا
فكيف ستسد اوروبا فجوه الامدادات الضخمه
هذه وهل سيكون هناك ما يكفي من الامدادات
البديله
استورد الاتحاد الاوروبي نحو 220 مليون
برميل من الديزل العمل الماضي وفقا
لبيانات مؤسسه فرتاكسا البديل الاكثر
وضوحا الذي يمكن لاوروبا الاتجاه اليه هو
الشرق الاوسط وهو الخيار الانسب نظرا
لقربها الجغرافي ومصا فيها الجديده وقد
تعاقدت ادنوك الاماراتيه بالفعل مع
المانيا على تصديره كميات اضافيه مؤخرا
البدائل الاخرى تشمل المصافي الهنديه
والامريكيه التي زادت شحنتها بالفعل الى
اوروبا في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه الا
ان الصين تحمل مفتاح كل الطاقه التكريريه
الفائضه عالميه ولو بطريقه غير مباشره
شحنات الديزل الخارجه من الصين ارتفعت
بشكل دراماتيكي في الاشهر الماضيه وعلى
الرغم من ان جزءا صغيرا من هذه الشحنات
يبحر الى اوروبا الا ان زياده الامدادات
من الصين ستحرر كميات كبيره لدى منتجين
اخرين ليصبح بالامكان نظريا توجها الى
اوروبا لكن ذلك سيتطلب زياده في الصادرات
الصينيه والاهم القدره على اعاده رسم
خريطه تدفقات الديزل العالميا اعتبارا من
فبراير المشكله ستظهر في حال لم تتمكن
روسيا من ايجاد اسواق بديله عن الاتحاد
الاوروبي ففي هذه الحال ستضطر الى خفض
انتاجي مصر فيها ما سيؤدي الى تق
الامدادات العالميه وبالتالي ارتفاع
الاسعار وحتى اذا وجدت روسيا مشترينا
اخرين فان شحنه منتجاتها لن يكون مهمه
سهله لان شركات الشحن ستكون حريصه على عدم
خرق العقوبات الغربيه لابد من الاشاره هنا
الى ان مجموعه السبع تناقش تطبيقا سقف
سعريا على المشتقات الروسيه على غرار
السقف السعري على الخام الروسي البالغ 60
دولار للبرميل والذي طبقته منذ بدايه
ديسمبر الماضي الا انها لم تتفق بعد على
سقوفا لاسعار المنتجات بعد
وهناك دور يمكن لتركيا ان تلعبه في هذا
المجال بما انها ليست ضمن الاتحاد
الاوروبي يمكنها نظريا ان تستورد كميات
كبيره من الديزل الروسي لتزويد سوقها
المحليه لتحرر في المقابل الكميات التي
تنتجها المصافي التركيه وتصبح متاحه
للتصدير الى اوروبا وباسعار اعلى لكن
الجانب الاخر للمساله هو المتعلق بالطلب
ففي ظل الشتاء الدافئ والتباطؤ الاقتصادي
قد لا تحتاج اوروبا الى الكثير من
الامدادات البديله الامر كله اذا يتعلق
بنمو طلب العلمي والاوروبي من جهه ومدى
حده انخفاض الانتاج الروسي فاذا اجتمعت
قوه هذين العاملين ربما تكون سوق المشتقات
النفطيه مقبله على مرحله صعبه واسعار
مرتفعه
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه كشف المنسق
الخاص للرئيس الامريكي لشؤون امن الطاقه
امس هوكستين لان الولايات المتحده تعيد
النظر حاليا في سحوبات من احتياطاتها
البتروليه الاستراتيجيه معدل البيع في
سبتمبر المقبل بحجم 30 مليون برميل ياتي
ذلك في ضوء توجه اداره بايدن مؤخرا لاعاده
بناء تلك المخزونات بعد ان سحبت نحو 180
مليون برميل منها خلال العام الماضي
لكننا في بدايه اللقاء ناقشنا مع هوكستين
الاثار المتوقعه لجوله العقوبات الغربيه
المقبله على السوق المشتقات عالمي»
[موسيقى]
محللوا اسواق النفط يتفقون بان الامتحان
الحقيقي لاسواق النفط قادم في الخامس من
فبراير المقبل وهو الموعد الذي يبدا
الاتحاد الاوروبي فيه تطبيق حضره على
استيراد المشتقات النفطيه الروسيه هل انتم
قلقون حيل اثر ذلك على اسواق المنتجات
النفطيه عالميا وتحديدا بالنسبه للديزل
ايوب
بعض المراقبين توصلوا الى قناعه بان وضع
السقف السعري للخام الروسي عند ال 60
دولار وهو سعر قريب مما يجنيه خام ليورال
حاليا في الاسواق قد يدلل بان الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها يرتبون الامور لحرب
طويله وممتده في اوكرانيا هل هذا استنتاج
صحيح
الاداره الامريكيه لم تكن سعيده بقرار
اوبك بلس بخفض الانتاج بواقع مليوني برميل
يوميا في اكتوبر الماضي ولكن وبعد مرور
هذا الوقت وبالنظر الى الوراء الم يكن هذا
القرار خفضا استداقيا ناجحا جدا قبيله ضعف
الطلب الذي تجسد لاحقا خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه
عرض
ارويش
باجه
اداره بايدن تخطط لشراء النفط الخام
لاعاده بناء مخزونتها النفطيه
الاستراتيجيه وذلك بعد انسحبت منها نحو
180 مليون برميل العام الماضي هي تخطط
لشراء ما يصل الى ثلاثه ملايين برميل
الشهر المقبل لكنها مازالت ستبيع نحو 30
مليون برميل في سبتمبر القادم اليس هناك
تخبط نوعا ما في تلك السياسات
عجوز
انطوني ثري فورد
الولايات المتحده صارت تستخدم عقوبات قطاع
الطاقه بشكل متزايد في الشؤون الخارجيه
يرى عدد من الخبراء بان الجولات الاخيره
من تلك العقوبات ستشكل نهايه للسوق
النفطيه العالميه الحره وستؤسس للسوق
نفطيه مقسمه وذات تدفقات تجاريه مجزئه هل
علينا ان نقلق حيل هكذا تداعيات
سكوزا بالعربي
[موسيقى]
يهوه
قربت الكهربائي الخليجي يوفر عوائد ب 300
مليون دولار سنويا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قربتم الكهربائي بين دول
الخليج مشروع بدا يحقق عوائد اقتصاديه ب
100 ملايين الدولارات فيما يجري العمل على
توسيع الشبكيه لربطه جنوب العراق بالاضافه
الى دراسه جدوى لربط مع الاردن ومصر عوايد
الربطه الكهربائيه وافاق مشاريع التوسعه
تناولناها في مقابله مع الرئيس التنفيذي
لهيئه الربطه الكهربائيه الخليجيه احمد
الابراهيم كان سؤالنا الاول عن حجم
التبادل الفعلي للكهرباء الذي تم من خلال
الشبكه العمل الماضي
طبعا احنا اتطلب على الكهرباء يرتفع في
فتره الصيف طبعا
ولدينا يعني امكانيه في ابرام الصفقات
بطريقه ثنائيه عن طريق منصه تجاره الطاقه
اللي عندنا فيها كهربائي خلال العام
الماضي وصلنا الى حوالي 800 جيجا وات ساعه
من التبادل التجاري بين الدول المجلس
التعاون وتطلع لنا ان شاء الله في
المستقبل يعني كميات اكبر من التبادل
التجاري ان شاء الله
مشروع التوسعه لتقومون عليه سواء كان مع
العراق او مع مصر لو تحدثنا اكثر عن
تفاصيله بالطبع مشاريع التاسعه هي من اهم
المشاريع والمرحله القادمه اللي جايين لها
عندنا مشروع الربط مع جنوب العراق مشروع
استراتيجي حيوي لدول المستعاون وجمهوريه
العراق همم بدانا التنفيذ الفعلي المشروع
خلال هذا الشهر وان شاء الله ان يكون همم
يدخل في حيز التشغيل مع نهايه العام 20 24
المشروع سيمد جنوب العراق بطاقه تبلغ 500
ميجاوات ان شاء الله ويمكن في المستقبل
الطاقه الى حوالي 1800 ميغاك باذن الله
تعالى ماذا عن خطط مع مصر ايضا لدينا
دراسه جدوى فنيه اقتصادي للربط مع الاردن
ومصر وايضا مشروع استراتيجي ربط استراتيجي
ليوم الاستعاون حاليا في مدرسه في في
مرحله الدراسات الجدول نتامل خلال هذا
العام ان شاء الله نخلص دراسات ونضع خطه
عمل مشتركه مع الدول هذه لتنفيذ المشروع
التنفيذ المشروع نتاملنا ياخذ من سنتين
الى ثلاث سنوات باذن الله تعالى
وما حجم الاستثمارات التي رصدت لمشاريع
التوسعه حاليا في عندنا استثمارات تفوق
الملياردولار حاليا عندنا يعني صفقات
تمويل وايضا مناقشات مع صناديق التنميه
الخليجيه والعربيه بشكل اكبر ونتامل ان
شاء الله نخلص كل هذه التموين خلال هذه
الاشهر القادمه المرحله الجايه بتكون مهمه
جدا
محتاجه لهذه التوسعه لدعم شبكات بشكل اكبر
لتوفير تبادل تجاري بشكل اكبر وهمم سيعود
ان شاء الله بمنفعه كبيره على دول مجلس
التعاون حاليا احنا نوفر على دول من
الساعه وان حوالي 200 الى 300 مليون دولار
سنويا الاقتصاديه مع التوسعه سوف ترتفع
هذه الفرات الى اكثر من نصف مليون ان شاء
الله سنويه بعد الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
تجاه اوروبا الى خفض اعتمادها على الغاز
والحصول على الكهرباء من مصادر اخرى هل
هناك اي اتفاقيه مع اوروبا لتبادل
الكهرباء
بلا شك ان الدول المشتعاون يعني في هناك
مناقشات هامه مع دول مع دول الاوروبيه
تطلع والرؤيه ان يكون هناك ربط بين دول
الخليج ودول اوروبا طبعا امكانيه نقل
الطاقه تعتمد على المشاريع لان سوف ننشئها
نحتاج مشاريع كثيره للربط وليس مشروع
ومشروعين عندنا طاقات كبيره في دول مجلس
التعاون تفوق ال 70 يمكن جيجاوات في فتره
الشتاء اللي ممكن السيسي منها
ونلبسها الى الى اوروبا بشكل تبادل
التجاري وخاصه بالنسبه حق مشاريع الطاقه
المتجدده هناك امكانيه كبيره ان احنا ننقل
هذه الطاقه المتجدده في حاله عدم الحاجه
اليها الى اوروبا عن طريق همم الربوطات
اللي بتكون ان شاء الله في المستقبل لذلك
هو ربطات استراتيجيه ودول مجلس التعاون
تنظر في هذه الروبوتات بشكل جديد
بالحديث عن الطاقات المتجدده ما هي نسب
الانتاج التي تدخل الشبكه من هذه الطاقات
بلا شك يعني اذا ننظر الى اهداف تطوير
الطاقه المتجدده في دول مجلس التعاون
الخاصه بالنسبه حق المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات هناك يعني
طاقات كبيره بتدخل في الشبكه دورنا احنا
شبكه خليجيه احنا نوفر السعه لتبادل هذه
الطاقات في حاله عدم الحاجه اليها وفي
حاله همم يعني نقص الانتاج من هذه فاحنا
نكون انيبلر ونكون يعني همم نساعد هذه
الشبكات على ادماج مصادر الطاقه المتجدده
فيها ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
اجرى المقابله الزميل يحيى الرفاعي
انا سعيده اخر مشاهدينا عمليه التحول في
قطاع الطاقه ستعتمد بشكل اساسي على
التكنولوجيا التي ستسمح بالتحول بشكل اكبر
واسرع الى الطاقات المتجدده والى انواع
الوقود منخفضه الكربون ومن بين ابرز
التقنيات تلك التي ستستخدم في انتاج
الهيدروجين النظيف الازرق والاخضر في هذا
السياق التقت او التقى مستقبل الطاقه مع
الرئيس والرئيس تنفيذي للعمليات في هاني
والفيمل كابور وسالناه عن التطورات التي
تشهدها تلك التقنيه
التكنولوجيا المتوفره اليوم كافيه لنتحرك
بشكل اسرع قليلا لكن ذلك لا يعني بان مزيد
من التكنولوجيات الجديده لن يتم العمل
عليها فعلى سبيل المثال نحن نعمل مع
العديد من عملائنا على تركيب تكنولوجيا
وقود الطيران المستدام في المصافي بعدد من
الدول مثل اوروبا وامريكا واسيا لانتاج
مزيد من هذا الوقود لارتفاع الطلب عليه
لذا هذه التقنيات حديثه نسبيا ايضا نحن
نعمل على انتاج مزيد من الهيدروجين وخصوصا
الازرق
اسرع مقارنه بمكانات عليه قبل عده اعور
ومن ناحيه اخرى هل هيدروجين الاخضر لا
يزال في مرحله لم تشهد التوسع على نطاق
كبير بعد ونحن فيها نويل مع مختلف
من هذه التقنيه اكثر كفاءه من خلال زياده
الانتاج اذا هناك تكنولوجيات المتوفره
اليوم وتكنولوجيات ستكون متاحه مستقبلا مع
مرور الوقت وسيكون هناك حاجه لدمجها مع
بعض في دوره تحول الطاقه
بالحديث عن الهيدروجين هناك اتجاه كبير
وعالمي الى هذا القطاع كيف سيخدم عمليه
تحول الطاقه
[موسيقى]
اكيد انه سؤال جيد اعتقد ان الهيدروجين
الازرق اصبح اكثر قدره على المنافسه
وتحديدا في الولايات المتحده بما يتماشى
مع قانون الحد من التضخم الذي يدعم تسريع
الانتقال للطاقه النظيفه كافه العملاء
اليوم يبحثون عن فهمي كيف يمكنهم ان
يتوسعوا في صناعه الهيدروجين الازرق وكذلك
الاخضر الذي يحتاجه لبضاعه اعوام ليصبح
على نطاق تجاريا بشكل اوضح لكن الهيدروجين
الازرق يبدو قريبا جدا لان يكون على نطاق
اوسع
وعند اي اسعار يمكن ان يكون هذا القطاع
وهو قطع الهيدروجين منافس للقطاعات الاخرى
عقدوا ان الهيدروجين اليوم يستخدم في
عمليه الانتاج في المصافي عندما تنظر اليه
كمصدر للطاقه وعلى سبيل المثال التدفئه
المنزليه يجب النظر الى الاسعار في ظل
الاستخدامات الحاليه والتي اليوم تعتمد
على الغاز الطبيعي لذا التكلفه ستكون
قابله للتنفيذ لا يوجد لدينا الرقم السحري
والذي يمكننا استخدامه مثل دولار لكل كيلو
ومن وجهه نظري ذلك يعتمد على اذا ما كنت
ستستخدم الهيدروجين كبديل يجب النظر الى
كلفه الدولار اعتمادا لما سيكون محله والى
ذلك الوقت الدعم الحكومي او الحوافذ
الضريبيه ضروريه للتوسع في هذه التقنيات
[موسيقى]
في هذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه
من مستقبل الطاقه دائما نتابعونا على
تويتر تحت وسم هاشتاج مستقبل الطاقه
يمكنكم ايضا الاستماع الى حلقاتنا على
العربيه
على موقعنا على الانترنت العربيه دوت نت
سلاش بروجرام
[موسيقى]